moving on
our main story tonight concerns policing
it's one of tv's favorite subjects from
hill street blues
through law and order through this
[Music]
[Applause]
now you're probably just currently
shouting what
increasingly loudly so let me quickly
explain that is a scene from
cop rock a very real musical cop show
that premiered on abc in 1990 and lasted
exactly 11 episodes think of it like if
pitch perfect crashed into the wire and
there were absolutely no survivors
now i'd say that was the best worst
thing that i've ever seen on tv but the
thing is
i have seen more cop rock there's a
subplot about child selling and if
you're wondering
does the child seller sing yep
[Music]
just a week or two
that song is three minutes long and they
never do
anything else that couple just stands
there while a man informs them that he's
the baby merchant
for three human minutes that show was on
television
in america but as long as we've been
questioning on tv whether policing has
and i apologize for even attempting this
racial overtures
we've made very little progress towards
actually addressing that issue
as we've discussed on the show before
the past and present of policing in
america is very much tied up
with racism and we want to focus on one
area of policing in particular tonight
police raids it's a practice that
attracted a lot of attention last year
in the wake of the brianna taylor okay
she was killed after officers broke down
her door in the middle of the night and
fired
32 shots into her home a year later
none of these officers have been
indicted for charges relating to her
death and if it is somehow nobody's
fault
that an innocent woman was killed in the
middle of the night in her own
home there might be an issue with police
raids
now data on them is pretty scarce so it
is hard to say exactly how many take
place in america but estimates
put it in the tens of thousands per year
and they can be carried out by
almost anyone in law enforcement from
federal agents to swat teams within
police departments
to detectives and patrol officers while
these tactics were initially intended
for life or death scenarios like
active shooters or hostage situations
one analysis found that only seven
percent of swot deployments met that
criteria
while more than 60 percent of the cases
involved searches for
drugs and that shift was the result of
intentional policy choices
police raids were supercharged by the
war on drugs and the tactic became so
popular that geraldo rivera
even produced a special where he showed
you raids happen in real time
this is real life the first in a series
of raids we'll be showing you this
evening
in this one members of the san diego
california police department
are raising a simple crack house
where pushers sell cocaine to people in
this neighborhood
for the past six months we have covered
the street cops whose job it is to rip
and tear and pound their way into the
nation's crack houses
and shooting galleries and we have gone
undercover to expose the pushers
who profit from this dirty business wow
they all seem to be having a lot of fun
there from the officer's mad dash like
it's black friday and walmart has a sale
on marijuana
to geraldo's ridiculous disguise which
was like the pringles guy
auditioning for miami vice although
we'll say that is still better than his
current look which answered the question
what if every single batman joker were
rolled into one
and raids can obviously have dire
consequences a times investigation found
that from 2010 to 2016
at least 81 civilians were killed in
them
and these tactics are rarely
proportional to the alleged crimes being
targeted in louisville
brianna taylor's home a year and a half
before the raid that killed her
this happened this police body camera
video shows lmpd swa officers breaking
into dougherty and burr's house on west
chestnut street
the couple and their three children who
were under the age of 16 at the time
claimed they were held at gunpoint the
morning of october 26
2018. 17 swat officers burst in because
a detective smelled marijuana coming
from the family's home
he smelled marijuana come on
if you just smell marijuana you don't
show up with loaded assault rifles like
you're in call of duty
you show up with settlers of catan and
50 worth of cookies from subway don't be
such squares and the thing is
absurdly disproportionate and dangerous
responses are basically par for the
course when it comes to police raids so
tonight
let's talk about them why they are such
a favored tool of police
why they really shouldn't be and what we
should do about that and let's start
with what you probably know already
which is that not all of us
are at equal danger of being raided when
cbs2 in chicago did an investigation of
several years worth of search warrants
they found that
certain neighborhoods tended to be hit a
lot more often than
others inglewood had 872 search warrants
also in the top five neighborhoods are
austin with 668
north lawndale 455 garfield park 442
and humboldt park with 3.76 census data
shows these neighborhoods are all nearly
90 percent or more black and latino
we found only a small percentage happen
in white neighborhoods
and none listed for edison park printers
row
wrigleyville museum campus and
magnificent mile
yeah that's about as as you'd
expect although i will say you didn't
actually have to tell me that those
neighborhoods are predominantly white
because
edison park museum campus and
magnificent mile are some of the whitest
sounding place names
i've ever heard right up there with
alabaster prim
spf 50ville and vermont and that racial
disparity has been found again
and again in louisville an examination
found search warrants
disproportionately targeted black
residents and a study of one year of
warrants in washington dc found
they were almost exclusively executed in
black communities
and police have been given tools to
carry out those warrants with increasing
force
police departments have become heavily
militarized after either purchasing or
just being handed
military equipment and some don't even
try to hide how much they enjoy using it
just listen to this officer introduce
one of his toys in a career day live
stream for kids
we call this the big bad wolf because
with enough force i can take this ram on
the front of this vehicle
and i can put it against a brick house
and i can go right through that brick
and i'd come right in your house if i
need to not your house because all of
you are good kids
we only do it for the bad kids oh
you do do you well that's reassuring
we've certainly got no reason not to
trust you to determine who's a good kid
and a bad kid
you're just a nice talkative guy who
apparently roots for the wolf
in the story of the three little pigs if
only the wolf had possessed
military-grade equipment you say as you
tuck your children in at night
fortunately your god-like father has no
such limitations on his powers
sleep tight good kids now there are
important questions
over whether or not police officers
really need access to that kind of
equipment
just as there are questions over what
messages they take away from some of the
training they receive
take a look at one particularly extreme
exercise for swat team members
the cult leader realizes that they got
an armored vehicle gonna start he goes
okay
let's pull the trigger sends out the rpg
and then they start executing people
oh my god it's really a mass suicide but
in fact it's really a murder suicide
none of the scenarios we saw left much
room for non-violent solutions
and then back in here the cult leader is
basically systematically
executing babies when the amount of
hours you spend at the shooting range
outnumber the number of hours you spend
learning conflict resolution and by
you know 10 or 15 to 1 you're going to
be more likely to use
the tool that you've trained more with
yeah no
because look i'm not saying that
they shouldn't be prepared for cult
leader baby murder but how many cult
leader baby murders do they think
they're going to be called to
every year i don't know what you're
thinking here but john if there is a
baby murder cult how are we going to
replace all those babies well don't
worry
i'm pretty sure i know a guy who can
help i'm the
baby merchant
seriously it's three minutes long it's
so weird
i'm not saying you should seek it out
i'm just saying you do need to know that
it exists
now the obvious danger of fostering a
militarized police culture that trains
and equips officers like that the lead
in an action movie
is that it can encourage them to then
act that way take a look at a raid that
took place in little rock here
the police blow open the door of the
apartment belonging to a man named
roderick talley because
they falsely believed he was selling
cocaine but despite not finding any
when they realized he had a home
security camera they asked him
what he was still cuffed to a chair if
they could re-watch the footage of their
raid so they could see how it looked
that's awesome i'ma record that real
quick
[Music]
yeah don't worry we're not laughing at
you we're just high-fiving ourselves for
how cool it looked when we blew your
door in but you get it
you were there by the way thanks for
being such a good sport about this even
though we do all have guns so you kind
of have to be
this job is fun and police might point
to the fact that they don't just use
guns they also have supposedly
non-lethal tools at their disposal but
even then there can be issues
take flashbang grenades in theory they
just stun
and disorient people but they can
generate heat in excess of 2
000 degrees so you'd hope officers would
be really careful with them certainly
a lot more careful than this we heard a
loud
a loud noise which was busting through
the door
then came a flash grenade right into the
two-year-old's bed
you can see by this picture how badly it
was damaged
and i kept begging the officer you know
give me my son just let me hold him he's
scared he needs me
the officer told me to shut up and go
sit down police were looking for drugs
but found
nothing yeah the police threw a
flashbang grenade
into a crib and look i'm no policeman
i haven't studied all the bylaws i don't
have a phd in grenadology but purely as
a layperson
the police should not have thrown that
grenade into a crib
and if the police are truly incapable of
knowing
whether they're throwing a grenade into
a crib maybe they shouldn't have
grenades here is another quick
rule that applies to both horseshoes and
hand grenades
if you throw either of them into a crib
even one time guess what
you don't get to play with them anymore
now thankfully
that couple's baby survived but it is
hard to believe
the police didn't realize there were
children in the house given that the
family had lived at that address
for two months and there was a minivan
with four car seats in the driveway
and when they did find the man that they
were actually looking for at a different
house
he surrendered peacefully when officers
knocked on his door so in hindsight
grenading a baby might not have been
necessary
and again they were looking for drugs
and again
they didn't find what they were looking
for this happens
all the time and troublingly police
don't have to work very hard
to get a warrant to blow someone's door
open judges
have to sign off on warrants and ideally
they would function as a check here but
in practice
they often don't spend much time
scrutinizing police justification
an investigation in utah of more than 10
000 electronically submitted warrants
found that half the time judges approved
warrants
in less than three minutes with hundreds
signed off in less than 30 seconds
that is absurd even the cases on
chrissy's court
were longer than 30 seconds and it was a
show on quibby
a platform we all collectively
fever-dreamed
and the bar for getting a judge to sign
off on a search warrant is pretty low
all you need is probable cause or a
reasonable belief
that evidence of a crime will be found
in the place you want to search and that
belief
can come from anywhere whether it's the
smell of marijuana or very often
the word of a confidential informant who
might be trading tips
for money or leniency and a lot of those
tips turn out to be complete
to get the search warrant that
led to the raid on roderick talley's
home
police told a judge that a confidential
informant had bought cocaine from him
and that they'd observed the interaction
but luckily
tally had a doorbell cam that showed the
informant
walking up to the door alone standing
there
and then walking away and look normally
i'm not a big fan of doorbell cams
all they do is record me giving myself a
five minute pep talk before i enter
any party but in this instance i'm
really glad he had one
and police have sometimes been caught
making informants up
giving misleading information in their
warrant application or
failing to do even the most basic
checking to see if their suspect is
actually in the home they're raiding or
somewhere else that they probably should
have known about
jolanda blassinggame says it was utterly
terrifying chicago police allegedly
breaking her door down in north lawndale
pointing rifles at her children
in what's being called a colossal police
blunder
they did not bother to perform the
simplest
most routine verification the target of
the warrant
mr bell was at that time serving a
20-year prison sentence for a murder
conviction
200 miles away in hill correctional
center in galesburg illinois
well that's pretty embarrassing but i
guess it's kind of like when you turn
your home upside down looking for your
keys only to discover they were in your
pocket the whole time
only in this case the keys are a man the
home isn't yours and your pocket is a
medium security prison in another
zip code so when you have bad police
work on the front end
and minimal judicial oversight on the
back end it becomes far
too easy to get a search warrant and
once police have one
there really aren't a lot of limits on
what they can do just about
every search warrant gives officers
permission to break down a door
to conduct a search and i know there's a
lot of talk right now specifically about
no knock rates but it's worth noting
that the line between
knock and no knock is very very thin
thanks to a series of court rulings like
this the u.s supreme court ruled today
police do not have to wait more than 20
seconds before breaking into a drug
suspect's home
the anonymous ruling said waiting any
longer would let suspects flush evidence
down the toilet
yeah the ruling there was giving you 20
seconds to answer your door
is reasonable because you might flush
evidence down the toilet which does
raise the obvious question here
why the are we raiding people's
homes for an amount of evidence that can
be flushed away in 20 seconds
unless someone is accused of trafficking
smurfs or stealing the world's most
valuable goldfish
maybe we should be finding a different
way to do this
and police really aren't incentivized to
give you any seconds to answer your door
because
in 2006 the supreme court ruled that
even when they violate the rules
requiring them to knock announce and
wait the prosecution
can still use the evidence obtained
during that search
so there is often no meaningful
consequences to
busting right through your door and
decisions like that mean the distinction
between
a no knock raid and a knock and announce
raid
is barely there as a judge in georgia
put it either the door comes in
and people are yelling sheriff's office
or people yell sheriff's office and the
door comes in
and that is fundamentally the same it's
like comparing
bryce dallas howard and jessica chastain
are they different
nominally sure although not in any way
that really means anything
now if you do actually need to tell them
apart bryce dallas howard is the one who
looks slightly more
like jessica chastain and on top of all
of this
there is just case after case of the
police messing up the execution of a
raid
that ranged from the horrific to the
almost cartoonishly idiotic
like this video of them looking for a
suspected drug dealer but instead
raising the home of his neighbor henry
norris a 78 year old with heart problems
who thankfully survived
despite the police making one mistake
after another
how did deputies end up hitting a house
with a different color
a separate driveway its own mailbox and
another
address missed
missed it first the tactical team got
lost following instructions from a gps
app on a phone
then as soon as they got to the correct
address
deputies were immediately confused
where's the house
where's the house they walked right past
the target house without clearing it
and headed through the tree line to the
next house on the street
even then deputies were unsure this
house
this house looking back
and forth at the two houses it was too
late the entry team was already forcing
its way into henri's home
oh for sake it is humiliating to
watch a train tactical unit outfitted
with military hardware get so completely
stumped
by the mystery of more than one house
and you might be thinking oh come on i'm
sure that's just a one-off but the thing
is
mistakes like that happen all the time
it was a total nightmare for this family
when cops
burst into their home which turned out
to be the wrong address
that is the wrong apartment and that is
the one that the swat team
went inside sean and his wife who both
work full time
live here the people the police were
looking for
live here the dea is apologizing for
bursting into the rink family home
with the bradley county swat team only
later finding out that it was the wrong
home
that's not a mistake to make like you
have i mean hell you could have looked
at the mailbox
yeah exactly and the police hitting the
wrong address is just completely
unacceptable when the stakes are so high
even edible arrangements
manages to deliver to the correct
address and that business is just pure
chaotic evil
happy anniversary please enjoy this
flavorless crucified melon now amazingly
there often aren't consequences for
cases like those officers are rarely
criminally charged and even more rarely
convicted
botched raids usually aren't even
investigated
unless someone is killed the media gets
involved or there's a lawsuit and even
when they happen
police officers are protected from civil
liability by the doctrine of qualified
immunity
as for their departments they aren't
even responsible
for paying to repair a broken front door
or compensating residents for any other
losses or damages
even when they raise the wrong residence
which is
just absurd look this is obviously
incredibly dangerous and not just for
the people whose homes are raided
for the police too that same
investigation that found
81 civilians have been killed in raids
found that 13 police officers
had died as well which really shouldn't
be that surprising
these raids are by design highly
disorienting and for the people who are
woken up in the middle of the night to
the sounds of an armed invasion
they have to make a split-second
decision whether or not to defend
themselves
that is something everyone can
understand in georgia a republican state
senator got in trouble for saying
if police raided his home in a no-knock
raid he would shoot them dead
and when he was pushed on that he did
not back down
if somebody kicks down my door
unannounced they will meet with
resistance i guarantee you
but if it's law enforcement they would
be there how am i supposed to know at
three o'clock in the morning
somebody shows up in black outfits they
can say they're law enforcement maybe
they're not
they've got a gun pointed at me what are
you gonna do dale yeah
dale what are you gonna do now i know
that guy looks like a bit of a
belligerent but the thing is
this country is
full of belligerent arseholes and lots
of them have guns
and while it is easy for a white state
senator to fantasize about himself
or indeed dale mounting a hypothetical
armed resistance to a police raid
for those who actually do get raided
there are real consequences to those
actions if not death
then serious criminal charges just a few
hours after brianna taylor was killed
her boyfriend kenneth walker
who believed the police were intruders
was charged with attempted murder
for firing his gun during the raid and
allegedly injuring an officer in the leg
those charges were dropped but only
because he had national attention
and a good lawyer meanwhile 18 year old
tyler harrell
was sentenced to 13 and a half years in
prison
after he injured a police officer during
a surprise drug raid at his home
even though a jury found no proof that
he knew he was shooting at police
lives are getting destroyed through
police raids
and even if nobody gets physically hurt
that does not mean that no damage is
done
having your home violated is a
traumatizing experience
often exacerbated by how targets of
raids are treated
take angenette young a social worker in
chicago whose home was raided
and who fought hard to get the body
camera footage released to the public
even though
it's incredibly difficult to watch you
see them running up to the apartment
complex
with the battering ram in their hand it
was so
traumatic to hear the way the thing was
hitting the door
and it happened so fast i didn't have
time to put on clothes
and she was right they were in the wrong
house
we found they simply took the word of an
informant who gave them angenette
young's address
the informant claimed a 23 year old man
who was a known felon had a gun and ammo
inside
i don't know who that person is i've
been living here for four years and
nobody lives here but me
okay
yeah it is they broke into her home
having done next to
no due diligence and handcuffed her
completely naked
before eventually throwing a blanket
over her while she was still handcuffed
and then
they said you don't have to shout
shouting
is not the drastic measure being taken
here people shout for many reasons
because they want peanuts because they
don't want to get
up or just because the song told them to
when you are handcuffed naked in your
own home
because the police screwed up a search
warrant shouting should be in your
miranda rights
and when you treat people like that it
is clear you have no interest in forging
a healthy relationship with the
community you're supposed to be serving
instead the community has to live with
the knowledge that no space is truly
secure
from the threat of police violence that
is a message that is received loud and
clear
from a very young age so what do we do
about this
well i would argue that small changes
just aren't going to cut it here because
yeah
it would be better if search warrants
were harder to get and
officers were required to verify
information from confidential informants
and
that we didn't give military grade
equipment to people who can't be trusted
not to throw it into a crib but
that is just not
nearly enough and even reforms that
appear sweeping
can be pretty limited after brianna
taylor's death no knock warrants
were banned in among other places
louisville and virginia which initially
sounds good the thing is as you've seen
tonight the difference
between no knock and knock is basically
no difference at all
and i'd argue that there's a big
solution here that's actually staring us
right in the face and that is
stop doing drug raids just
stop it and if that sounds extreme you
might want to know the former chairman
of the national tactical officers
association
recommends that raids never be used to
serve narcotics warrants saying
why would you run into a gunfight you
definitely don't go in and risk your
life
for drugs and he's right drug raids
just have to stop and raids in general
should only be used as a
last resort to save lives that are in
immediate danger because
busting into someone's home is never
going to be safe
for anyone involved and right now raids
are being used
far too widely and are destroying lives
both for the individuals who are killed
injured or traumatized
and all the black and brown people who
have no choice but to internalize the
lessons of that trauma
they deserve the respect and
consideration of a police force that's
supposed to protect them
not one that merely sees their lives as
an opportunity for
action movie cosplay a thrilling tv
special
or the reenactment of a misremembered
nursery rhyme with a souped-up
battering ram and maybe just
maybe
if we can do the right thing here and
climb down from our current
wild overuse of raids then and only then
we'd have a police story legitimately
worth singing about
that's our show thank you so much for
watching we'll see you next week
good night